- It sound corny and cliche,
but there's always
sunshine after the rain.
You know what I'm sayin'?
Rain don't last that long.
You got to know that, to be aware of that.
Life is a game.
Life is a, it's a chess match.
You got to go into it confidently.
You can't be timid all the time.
Anything you put in
your subconscious mind,
it becomes a reality.
So, I tell myself,
constantly, this is easy.
This is easy.
No matter what the task is.
- He's the CEO and the founder
of a supplements company.
He's a former professional boxer.
He's the author of the
Overtraining series of eBooks.
He's Mike Rashid,
and here's my take on his
top ten rules of success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always, guys, as
you're watchin' the videos,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it down the comments below,
and put quotes around it,
so other people can be inspired as well.
Also, as you are writing something down,
it's much more likely to
stick in your head too.
Enjoy.
(inspiring music)
- There are different types
of people in this world.
And, one thing that we'll
all want to deal with,
is, like, difficulties, and our tasks,
tryna to become successful.
As good as things get, you get
out the same amount of bad,
that's going to try to
impede your progress,
whether it be people,
whether it be the IRS,
whether it be whatever.
Something will rear its ugly
head, and try to block you.
Now, a lot of people
can't handle that s***.
When you have a vision,
and something, or someone
throws a curve ball, it hurts.
It stings, right?
It's like your baby.
And now, I can't put my baby
out there like I want to do it.
So, it really throws people off.
They get really negative, make
it depressing, I want to stop.
Then, they want to just go
back to their nine-to-five.
That's fine.
It's not for everybody to push through.
But, for those who can push
through, like you said,
the difference between
those who really succeed,
and those don't, are the ones who'll,
when they're faced with
whatever these difficulties are,
they're like, f*** it,
I'mma keep f***** pushin' through.
I'mma keep pushin' through.
Because, it sound corny and cliche,
but there's always
sunshine after the rain.
You know what I'm sayin'?
Rain don't last that long.
You got to know that to be aware of that.
That's somethin' you can take with you
through with everything in life.
But, in business, you cannot stop,
because things are not
goin' right at the time,
'cause it's going to happen.
I've dealt with it.
I'm sure I'll deal with
it again, some point.
So anyway, I always make
sure I was the best,
in the best shape.
When people were in the gym,
they saw how serious
I was with my clients.
They also saw how hard I
was training on my own.
So, it was not hard for me to get clients.
Now, when I decided to leave
the gym and go independent,
this was already a goal of mine.
I've written out all of my goals.
Writing goals are very important.
It's very important.
I wrote my goals out.
And, I think it was, like, ten of 'em.
And then, a year later,
maybe two years later,
I went back to that
book, and I swear to you,
every thing I've written out, I hit it,
without even thinkin' about it.
It's somethin' powerful
about writin' your goals.
As a trainer, I work my ass off.
I had the worse hours, starting out,
five in the morning, you
know, and I closed the gym.
It's funny that I'm
thinkin' about this now,
because the end of my training career,
I had the same hours.
And I was a successful trainer at the end.
But anyway, I have a
break in the middle there,
but I'm workin' the worse, all the hours,
tryna generate business.
So, what I did, I established
a very solid clientele base.
A core group of people, a lot of 'em.
And I was very, very, very
dedicated to them, you know?
I would get, you know, all you
need, is one certification,
and I got three, you know what I mean?
Always try to better myself,
just reading, studying.
And I'll always try to
be the example as well,
making sure I'll never have
somebody come to my gym
that's in better shape than me.
That was my mind state.
When I expand, and this
is anything in my life,
I always have a lot.
When you see me, you see a lot of people.
I'll always have a lot of responsibility,
and I've always had a
lot of responsibility.
I'm not comfortable without
a lot of responsibility.
Some people, it spreads them thin.
But, I just grow more.
There's more of me now,
you know what I mean?
So, I'm tryna take on more
things, tackle more things.
I'm strong enough to do it, you know,
in every sense of the word.
And I truly believe, I just know it.
It is what it is.
You know, and my mentality is like,
I have a, I don't lose mentality.
And that's with anything.
That's not just, like, say, a
sporting event, or whatever.
That's just life, right?
Because life, is non-stop tests.
You know what I mean?
And we're always bein' put to tests.
There's always challenges,
obstacles, et cetera.
And I, literally, don't accept
any of that as a impediment,
as a negative.
It's like, good, this is
going to make me stronger.
I'm going to learn somethin' from this.
You don't have no life,
especially when you're a
successful personal trainer,
you know?
It's hard to take a vacation,
because you take a break,
you don't train anybody for that week,
that's a week further that
you're going to get paid.
It's just a, you know,
any trainers out there,
you all know what I'm talkin' about.
But, it is a good job.
It is very rewarding.
You do learn a lot of leadership skills,
and you got to take it serious, though.
But, it was very nerve-wrecking,
very scary to step out,
and try to do things on my own.
But, you know what?
It was the best business
decision that I ever made,
and I'm glad I did it, you know?
I'm a risk taker.
You got to be willin' to take those risks.
You got to bet it all on
yourself, and believe in yourself.
And you'll be alright.
And listen, you all.
Like, when you take that
risk, when you step out there,
and step away from that safe nine-to-five,
you have to, and I didn't rely on nobody,
family, friends, nobody.
I just had me.
You have to survive.
You have to make it.
You in deep water, you
either drown, or you swim.
It's up to you.
I was livin' fast for a while, man.
Like, I've always been a very...
Like, I've always had
a lot of force behind,
in everything I do.
I was always successful, whatever I did.
So--
- Maybe, like adventurous?
- Well, I was never scared to take risks.
- Right, right.
- So, I appeared
when I was taking the wrong
kind of risks, you know?
And, my lifestyle--
- What do you think
kind of led to that?
Like, just kind of hangin'
around the wrong dudes,
the wrong people?
- You know what?
It just, my, just being stupid, man.
Just like--
- Like, being young and just--
- Yeah, young and stupid.
- Thinkin' you're cool,
thinkin' you're tough.
- I was raised in a really good family.
My father's a very intelligent person.
- Yeah.
- Like, I refer to his quotes
and wisdom, all the time.
- Yeah.
- So, I was raised--
- Yeah, same here,
with my pops, yeah.
- But, I just got to a point, man,
yeah, I guess, the
people who was around me.
I had a bunch of parasites
and leeches around me.
And, you know, I liked it,
for whatever weird reason.
You know what I'm sayin'?
And I wanted to be--
- Yeah, some people
are attracted to that kind of thing.
- Yeah, so, but I learned my lesson,
and I corrected my ways.
I had to go through a lot.
Like, being homeless-type s***.
You know what I mean?
- Wow.
- Almost losin' my freedom.
And, you know, I went through a lot,
and I kept my head up, I persevered.
I didn't lay down to my problems.
I handled 'em, I faced it,
and came out so much better.
- Right.
- I got so much to give people now,
because I did go through--
- Well, a lot of that
makes sense, now I'm
hearin' you sayin' it,
'cause the way that you
talk, is kind of stern,
and straight to the point.
- Right.
- And so, it's like, wow, that
guy kind of speaks powerfully.
That's 'cause you've been through it.
- Yeah, exactly.
- You dug yourself up.
You grabbed yourself
by the bootstraps, and,
were able to persevere.
- I got taken to deep waters,
and I swam back.
I've had other people in deep waters.
I swam out there, and brought them back.
- Right.
- Numerous times.
So, I've been through a lot.
- Right.
- And I feel like that
makes me so f***** strong.
I got to a point.
It was like a crossroads,
where I was, like,
lay down and die, and be a loser,
and my kids look at me in disgust.
Or, do somethin' with my life.
So, I did somethin' with my life.
So, I wrote out a plan.
This is somethin' that
people, that you got to,
you got to do.
You got to take serious.
This is a saying, I don't
know who say it, but,
I heard it from Nas.
It says, "People don't plan
to fail, they fail to plan."
So basically, everything
is a process, right?
So, if you or I won a million dollars,
we can go get a million dollars.
It's no different than makin' a sandwich.
You learn, when you're makin'
a sandwich, what do you do?
You get up, you walk to the
kitchen, get your bread out.
You go through a process.
- Yeah.
- It's the same thing
with becoming successful
in whatever you want to do,
so, or, whatever your goal is.
You figure out what that process is.
You do your research, you ask people.
And then, you make a
plan, you write it out.
Confident people get a lot further in life
than people that are not confident.
It is what it is,
because a confident person will
step out, on his own faith,
and try to do things outside
of the norm, you know?
A confident person will take chances,
that a non-confident
person won't, you know?
I'm not saying be arrogant.
I'm not saying be an
asshole, none of that,
'cause I don't like people
like that, you know?
But, bein' confident, is
nothin' wrong with that.
You know, I got a sports background,
most of you all do too.
You know, I used to box.
I'mma go in the ring, confident as ****,
to let this guy know that I'm
tryin' to knock his head off.
You know what I'm sayin'?
I want him to know, or think, in his mind,
that I know, for a fact, that
I'mma knock his head off.
You know what I mean?
That little mental intimidation
is going to go a long way,
in that particular fight, in
that boxing match, you know?
And that's life.
Life is a game.
Life is a, it's a chess match.
You got to go into it confidently.
You can't be timid all the time, you know?
I'm not sayin' just leap
out of the fryin' pan,
into the fire, in every situation.
You got to be smart and calculative.
However, if you don't have
that confidence, you know,
it's some bulls out there.
There'll tear you apart.
It's dog-eat-dog sometimes, you know?
And people, just like animals,
humans can smell fear.
They can see a timid person.
A lot of people don't
want to go into business
with a timid person.
A lot of people can't
trust a timid person.
A lot of people don't want a timid person
to have their back.
They don't want to be a
team with that person.
I lift, I lift pretty
much five days a week.
I lift, probably about, my sessions,
sometimes, they can be 30
minutes, sometimes, 90 minutes.
So, it varies.
And also, guys, I've been
liftin' since I was a young guy.
I started, I think I started
actually lifting weights
when I was 12 years old.
We had those concrete weights
with the plastic that covers it.
You know, the sun kind
of cracks the plastic,
and every time you do a curl,
a chunk of cement falls out,
so the weight's imbalanced.
One thing I can say about
my lifting regiment,
is I am very consistent.
I can't think of a time in my life
that I haven't been training,
and that's every group
of friends I've ever had.
I'm the ringleader when
it comes to training.
Like, everybody's training,
'cause I'm around.
So, I've been lifting forever.
I'm thinkin' about makin'
the hardest thing look easy.
So, if you're ever around me when I train,
a lot of times, I'm psyching myself up.
I'm like, this is easy!
This is ****** easy!
This is a ****** warm up!
Give me more weight!
I say that to myself, and
I believe it, you know?
Anything you put in
your subconscious mind,
it becomes a reality.
So, I tell myself,
constantly, this is easy.
This is easy.
No matter what the task is.
Now, you take that, it's
bigger than the gym, okay?
This is a direct parallel to
life, to everyday situations,
whether it be work, school, relationships,
facin' a conflict, okay?
When you consciously put yourself
through a difficult task,
say, like a really difficult
workout in the gym,
when it's somethin' positive for you,
you constantly put yourself through that,
you will be able to,
like, outside the gym,
handle any situation,
because you've developed
that mental toughness.
It's way more than physical,
and that's what I try to get across.
My training, the way I train, is yeah,
I want to be physically
fit, I want to be strong,
I want to be healthy, I want to look good.
But also, I want a strong mind, okay?
And I tell people all the time,
train your mind as hard
as you train your body.
- Thank you guys so much for watching!
I made this video, because JP asked me to.
So, if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it down in the comments below,
and I'll see what I can do!
I'd also love to know what
did you learn today from Mike,
that had the biggest impact on you?
What message really stuck with you,
that you're going to,
immediately, apply, somehow,
to your life, or to your business?
Leave it down in the comments below,
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
I'd also want to give a quick
shout out to Vishal Singh.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and making that
fun YouTube tribute video.
I really, really, really
appreciate your support.
("Hall of Fame" by The Script)
- So thank you guys, again, for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.
- Personal training is a
very, very rewarding job,
in more ways than one.
You can make decent money
as a personal trainer,
but it's not about the money.
It's about, really, changing these lives,
like, touching lives.
I've had people, I had
a woman who I helped,
I helped her lose a hundred pounds.
She was like this, she was
an obese, morbidly obese.
And when I was done with her,
she was a hot, fit chick.
There was a old guy.
I loved this guy.
He was in his 70's.
Very, very sedentary lifestyle.
With him, it wasn't about
the lifting weights.
We did a few things for
resistance training,
but, you know, I threw
some boxing gloves on 'em,
and held mitts, and it gave him life.
He loved it.
So, you find what these people want to do.
You find somethin' that works for them,
somethin' that's going
to keep them healthy,
alive, and vibrant, and then
you run with that, you know?
So, it was very rewarding in that sense.
Well, like I said, overproduce.
Whatever your role is, do more.
I don't care if you work at McDonald's.
Do more.
Because, what you're doing,
is you're making yourself important.
You're not going to be the
guy, when budgets need to be,
when budget cuts are on a table,
your name is not even going
to be in the conversation.
Out, we need him.
Everybody else, you know what I mean?
And, you're developing an
impeccable work capacity,
and ethic, which, if you
ever do become your own boss,
or manager, or whatever,
you already have that
achievement unlocked already.
You know what I mean?
So, that's somethin' that
you definitely want to do.
So, overdevelop.
And I tell people, it's
about bein' a winner.
You know, my supplement
company's called I'm So Alpha.
I didn't come up with that, you know?
I will put stuff out, like
pictures and videos, and stuff,
and like, people would just hashtag, like,
"That's so alpha.
"So f***** alpha.
"We love that s***."
It's just a mind state, right?
So, and when I say that, like,
people think, oh, that's
super arrogant and cocky.
It's not.
There's nothin' wrong with
bein' confident, for one,
because (clears throat)
when you are legitimate,
when you really, like, qualify yourself,
in whatever field you're in, you know,
and you handle business, you
got the work to show for it,
why not be confident, you know?
Some people mistake that
for arrogance, or cockiness.
I'm not about that.
You know, I'm about
bein' confident, though.
I can't help it, you know?
So, you conduct yourself in a certain way.
So, it's a whole lifestyle that I push,
with the type of training that I do.
You know, it goes into my everyday life.
I can't help it.
You know, that's why the
company's I'm So Alpha.
I hashtag, and I got shirts
that say, Alpha as ****.
It's like, I'm really
going to ****** do this,
you know what I mean?
Whatever it is, anything,
like, any kind of challenge,
I'm like, I want to do it.
I want to do it.
Oh, that's hard?
Yeah, I think, okay, let me do it.
I'mma do it harder, and I'mma, you know?
Add more weight, and I'mma do it,
you know what I'm sayin'?
So, you know, it just, mentally,
it sets you up for life, to be a winner,
'cause I'm all about bein' a winner.
And I'm not talkin' about on stage.
That's not really winning, is it?
You know, it's not a competition.
You're just gettin' judged,
by people who don't lift,
you know what I'm sayin'?
(group laughing)
Winning in life, winning
in life is like...
Winning in life is like, you know,
your kid is struggling in a subject.
You figure out a way
to get 'em up to speed.
You know, you got a argument
with your girlfriend,
or your boyfriend,
you're not going to let this
person walk away, unhappy.
Like, you all going to figure it out.
You know what I mean?
That's winning in life.
You know what I'm sayin'?
There's a conflict at work, you handle it.
You step up and handle it.
You're winning at life,
you know what I mean?
And that's what it's all
about, bein' a winner,
at life, at everything.